the trend that I think is really
important and up and coming over the
next five years that you can really see
in young London designers is people
being really individual and authentic to
themselves so is about it's about being
yourself it's about doing what you want
to do
I think experimentation will definitely
grow within fashion which is what makes
us free I think that the future of
fashion is going to be a constant
political statement people will say and
this is what I feel and this is what I
wants you to do my graduate collection
it was all about the rioters uprising
against the government and you know
being for like the people and listening
to them I feel like there could be this
moment that like be one of reacts true
our clothing with everything it would be
good to see you know like more women of
color in the future of fashion not only
on you know the cover of the magazines
were also within the industry itself
behind the scenes I think that's really
important I definitely take the trends
will be more unisex Gorem winners I've
currently made a unisex knitted
collection based on where I'm from which
is Middlesbrough I think that the man
will feel more comfortable with being
what is said in our society has more
feminine but if that just as flamboyant
as men were in historical terms
I think sustainability is a massive one
no matter what industry you're in like
you can sort of tackle it now rather
then you know ten years down the line
it's just going to be a lot easier the
hope is for me is that we'll be able to
print fabrics using 3d printing and for
someone who wants to do fashions that
are sustainable this is very very very
exciting for me I'd love to see that
printed graphics take like leaps and
bounds like a Jif print totally Blade
Runner
it is really motivating to work with
seven other designers in the house of
Paris studio you're learning from each
other and you're just sharing and
experiencing this thing together it's
important for brands to set up
initiatives like this because I guess I
guess we're the few did you know we have
all of these dreams that that are so
difficult to realize at the start we we
don't have a platform and has brainy
provides us but a few do and amazing
mentorship and all of these things that
are invaluable
it'll be so difficult to it without that
so difficult
[Music]